seen this video so many times this is
okay so in the manosphere is like men's
Centric content okay so in men's central
content they'll talk about things like
dating advice right and a lot of times
like the men what they would do is
they'd come to women and tell us what
they really think because there's a lot
of stuff like submission you probably
never really heard that before and so
this guy Kevin had a college
that was the most oh my gosh yeah it was
so funny have you ever seen him no no
never okay okay those were hers
hey can you hear me yeah are you a PhD
ah no I'm a PhD how many dollars you got
one really
I'm sorry what kind of dog is it he's a
Cane Corso
he's a what a Cane Corso what is that in
English
um the larger dog and their breed is
okay so what's your disagreement
um honestly I don't have a disagreement
I just came here because I honestly want
some advice from you
foreign
catching on live normally I'm asleep and
uh you have a job
I do I own a business okay so I do too
and I do have a question but I have a
business and if you wanted my advice you
could always book a session if you can't
catch us at the show live I'm definitely
I was trying to go online
um earlier but all you have to do man
but see what kind of business do you own
okay so what you're basically trying to
do is I have a disagreement day and you
basically came in and said damn your
topic I want to ask you what I want to
ask you and that's but you're more than
welcome to go on my website and purchase
your time to talk with me one-on-one
because what you're trying to do is
rather rude but I will go ahead and do
it you think he's right yeah yeah of
course now this woman didn't know she
was about to sign up to be an internet
sensation because he wasn't that big at
this point okay but this this video
broke the internet you'll see why you'll
see because I'm going to use this as a
teaching lesson
how old are you I'm 35. 35 years old
35 years old and you're a business owner
uh-huh uh-huh and what's your question
um so my issue is well I want to know at
what point when um
just meeting a guy do I tell him that
I'm a business owner because
um my problem is that when I try to date
down and I the conversation comes up to
where I own the business
um the guys either like hey can I come
join in on you on that business or can I
put somebody be a business partner and
I'm not looking for that and I honestly
oh oh hold on hold on hold on hold on I
need to be clear on this subject
where are you where are you at North
Carolina
and you're saying when to tell somebody
you own a business
because
um I find when I date down God to your
interest and want to be like a business
partner and um I'm learning that maybe I
need a high value man because that's
what well first off
um
ma'am I really understand uh what kind
of man are you talking about
because owning a business is no
different than having a job in my
opinion
I'm not getting what you're saying when
should you I'm not understanding why
this is an issue what do you think so
far yeah because it doesn't really make
sense what she's saying what do you mean
like whenever whenever you feel
comfortable telling them you own a
business just tell them well just don't
tell them since you see that the results
if I didn't want to tell someone what I
did I just say oh I work in marketing I
don't care
is it really that it's never that
serious for her to come onto his show at
this point knowing that it's a it's what
is it
blue hair I do why would you do that do
that it's weird guys
I do I do have blue hair
you just noticed that
oh I do oh my gosh can we dye it back
you know what it is
polycystic ovarian syndrome causes my
hair like to like I get I lose hair I
lose a lot of hair so then me dying is
like why not make it more
like
like a puppy
it's really sad and I feel a little bad
for you oh
me too but can we die I'll pay for it
I mean
I can definitely
dye it back it's okay that's not being
used
okay yeah hopefully
but yeah I'm just gonna
cover that up just ignore it just it
never existed
if you're if you're I'll do this to my
sister
what the hell are you dating
I always say what type of men are you
dated I've never had a guy care and I I
I have a business I've never had a guy
here to join my business like does that
even make sense do you date men with no
jobs
that's a question oh
um I'm trying to give I try to give guys
that not serious you try to do what I
try to give guys that's not on my level
a chance why what do you mean on your
level what does that mean that's making
six figures or more
but I don't under okay you try to give
guys who are not on your level a chance
wow
because I want I honestly want a six
figure guy
um is what I'm realized okay so let me
just go ahead and net it out for you
you ready uh-huh
the guys you want aren't asking you out
well I'm I haven't been to put myself
out there honestly
you put yourself out there enough for
the guys you don't want or relief you to
ask you out
those are like guys I met online
right so again
the men you want are not asking you out
See you ladies do this
you go and deal with men who you feel
are beneath you and then you ask how to
fix them I'm not beneath you I don't
know how to fix a guy that doesn't
that's down there that's not my concern
the better question is why can't you get
a guy on your level
that's the real question
well first of all I would tell you what
I said in here automatically is a
problem
why you would come onto a show that you
know was a disagreement day
it's selfish
it's like well yes ma'am it's so it's
like I want what I want
I I don't I don't say things for no
reason
that's why I asked you questions you're
35 years old a business owner that means
you understand what business is and you
know this is a business and I have a and
I have a show title and you said damn
your show title I want to talk to you
but you could have went to my business
and book time to talk to me but you
wanted what you wanted how you want it
sorry no it's but and I'm using this as
lessons done it after you've done it you
know what did I say I'm sorry you feel
embarrassed this is like what people
would always say he was harsh right no
but he's being honest he's being honest
that's like yesterday like when we were
talking about the following yeah and
everyone was like well well he shouldn't
be following those girls and I'm like
but why did you find it in the first
place yeah and that's and then it just
shows you crazy it's okay I feel crazy
like if I'm not saying I'm not saying
I'm above it
I'm just like we just gotta you gotta
identify the problem in order to fix it
yes but it's like why is women can we
never hear criticism for men or women
without it being more too emotional
she's emotional she knows she grew up in
Nigeria guys she's based
exactly yeah it's a problem with too
many of you black women you don't do
the right way with black men
that was improper and when I even when I
told you the right way you still were
like uh well whatever
so I'm gonna use this
when was the last time you had a
relationship
um like the end of last year around
December how long did it last a year
a year uh and was that man uh did you go
to college
did I go to college
yes
I think I don't remember I think she
says no and I always know when girls
repeat questions back to you that means
they don't want to answer guys guys hold
on I need to read a Super Chat
Charlie Brown she's back in the chat
let's give a Charlie Brown yay Super
Chat are you you and your content how
can I become a member I intend to join
your event in shy town since you won't
be coming to the Twin Cities anytime
soon okay so oh my gosh I need to put my
link in the chat okay I don't want you
guys seeing what's going on on my
computer you know
um but guys we are doing a meet up we
are doing a meet-up in
um what do you call it in Chicago I'm
going to a bunch of cities for some
podcasts and you know looking at cities
to move to we're going to be going to
Chicago We're going to be going to
La we're also going to be going to Miami
and
um Nashville so if you want to be
notified make sure you sign up for the
email list it's in the description or
it's in the I just pinned the comment in
the chat
if you want to be a part of my
memberships okay that lets you be a part
of the live chat
um you can see behind the scenes Vlogs
one-on-one call with me once a month All
That Jazz
that you go to my page and click join
memberships
um I think I don't actually know
something like that but for real please
sign up for the members the email list
that's the most important thing to me
right now put in your phone your email
you'll be texted when I'm in different
cities I won't bombard you I swear we're
also okay you know I call fat chicks
whales you do yeah I do
um it's because they are
afraid of them anyway you know I'm
afraid of the fatties so so only obese
only obese you know chubby is okay but
obese I can't I'm just I'll just hide
under my bed
[Music]
[Laughter]
um anyways we're gonna do some whale
merch so it's gonna say I'm gonna have
the types of whales and then it's gonna
have like a beluga whale and then it's
gonna have a fat chick in the middle
well then on YouTube so so I gotta I
gotta sell it somewhere else you know
what I mean that is genius
um yeah so if you guys want that sign up
for the email list to be notified I'm
trying to figure out the marketing stuff
someone else said saint Sarah red pill
her Pearl look at guys
I'm a red pillar okay she's never gonna
see the world the same after I'm done
with her you wait you wait maybe not
this episode once she sees Jordan
Peterson it's over
okay and how long have you owned your
own business
nine years
and how and how long have you been
making six figures or more
on the last three okay why do you need a
man making six figures
um because I'm finding out that the guys
that I date that's not is not
what does it have to do with money oh my
gosh I put the wrong link I put the
wrong link guys that is not the right
link I just realized okay hold up I
don't wanna I wanna show you guys the
stream key or nothing
gotta delete this one
I'm sorry guys I'm sorry okay here's the
actual link I fixed it okay
Place pinned messages okay my bad guys
my bad all right now back to the video
I'm sorry
sorry because I feel like
um I need a guide that I can respect and
admire and I'm ambition ambition and I
want a guy
that has that drive too and when he
doesn't I find myself you know
encouraging like hey babe you can do
this and you can do that and then all
right so in North Carolina
how what percentage of the population
what percentage of men in this country
make six figures or more what do you
think that is
six figures in the US is like 80 000
pounds here and it's roughly the
percentages are similar okay
I have zero three I'm not going to lie I
would say
what percent yeah of men make that much
money
forty percent forty percent is that a
lot is that too much that's way too much
[Laughter]
social media does I think all these
people the average salary is like 40
like 45 really thousand I think in the
US I think here it's like 40 000 pounds
or something like that I think it's five
five percent I'm not closer to ten so oh
10 all right so the question is what do
those men who make that kind of money
who all women tend to want
what do they want
I feel like they want arm candy somebody
who can um have more to bring to the
table than just looks but um
also bring as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible